y vamos
uno de los mentores que fue muy
importante para mí cuando decidí que
quería hacer gráficos por computadora
fue mariah palas y ella era la directora
del centro de computación avanzada para
las artes y el diseño de la universidad
estatal de ohio la conocí cuando estaba
en la preparatoria le hablé sobre mis
intereses y me dijo hay un campo donde
puedes usar tu gusto por el arte y el
diseño y tu afición por la ciencia y la
programación y ese campo son los
gráficos por computadora y me enseñó su
centro y lo que hacen y pude ver todas
las cosas increíbles que los estudiantes
de posgrado estaban haciendo ahí y pensé
aquí es donde yo pertenezco bueno este
es uno de mis proyectos como estudiante
una de las cosas que más me gustaba
hacer con mis proyectos como estudiante
era entender cómo las señales pueden
trasladarse entre sí para crear
diferentes apariencias en una red de
herramientas de acabado así es que aquí
estuve jugando muchísimo con redes de
herramientas de acabados y preguntándome
el puedo cambiar un fractal de alta
frecuencia puedo alternar lo
conversiones saturadas y no saturadas de
esta textura y pensé que era tan
increíble que podemos usar señales
relativamente simples para combinar
mapas de texturas complejos y terminar
con estos acabados tan interesantes algo
que me encantaba de este trabajo es que
cada que escribía un fragmento de código
o establecía una conexión inmediatamente
podía haber un resultado visual de lo
que estaba haciendo y así es como me
encantaba aprender a programar porque
tener resultados visuales del trabajo
que estaba haciendo era súper alentador
y sobre todo para mí porque yo era una
aprendiz
super activa era verdaderamente útil
poder ver un resultado en cuanto hiciera
algo otra de las razones por las que
escogí los gráficos por computadora
lo que estaba sucediendo en esos tiempos
estaba yo tan inspirada por el corto
bony que pensaba que era lo más bello
que había visto
siempre me he sentido tan conmovida
cuando los animales y personajes cobran
vida y eso es algo que se puede hacer
muy bien con las marionetas pero es algo
que los gráficos por computadora hacen
excepcionalmente bien simplemente es el
formato adecuado para estas cosas y
ratatouille se acababa de estrenar y me
enteré de que pixar iba a venir a
visitar nuestro campus y yo me moría por
hablar con esas personas que hicieron
esa comida que se veía tan deliciosa
tuvimos una muy buena conversación y
les gustó mi trabajo y me preguntaron si
quería ir a pixar a hacer algunas
aplicaciones de acabado y lo hice y mi
jefa era la creadora de aquella hermosa
comida en ratatouille al teaneck xenakis
fue increíble llegar y que me asignaran
esa tarea el primer día no podía creer
mi suerte estaba emocionadísima y en mi
currículum había una línea que decía
pasatiempos y en esa línea de
pasatiempos puse después tejer tocar el
piano coser
y uno de los directores técnicos de
supervisión vio esa línea y me dijo oye
espera tú sabes cómo usar los programas
de computadora y puedes conocer sabías
que hay trabajos en pixar para personas
que pueden hacer ambas cosas y le dije
no y me dice te gustaría probarlo y le
dije por supuesto que sí y así
encontraron un lugar para mí en walt y
acababan de recibir comentarios de una
presentación preliminar y los personajes
no tenían un tamaño que hiciera feliz al
público así es que cambiamos el tamaño
de los personajes y era necesario
ajustar sus vestuarios y ese era un
trabajo perfecto para una pasante
después me asignaron a él y confecciones
su vestuario y la vestí y simplemente no
podía creer mi buena suerte porque es un
personaje maravilloso es extrovertida
inteligente y divertida las cosas
salieron muy bien con él y les gustó mi
trabajo y yo también estaba muy contenta
por lo que me pidieron que trabajara con
mérida loco
fue increíble y también salió muy bien
después trabajé con disgusto y con
reilly y con toda la ropa de la mamá de
rail y eso fue muy divertido y ahora
estoy trabajando en algo que
definitivamente no puedo decir frente a
la cámara si este es un campo que te
interesa o si hay cualquier otro campo
que te interese y sucede que miras a tu
alrededor y piensas como que no hay
muchas personas en este campo que se
parezcan a mí no importa encontrarás tu
lugar sólo involucra te consigue
excelentes mentores haz muy buenos
amigos y te en la confianza de que si lo
deseas suficiente ese es tu lugar
gatito
dios mío hay un gato
gatitos
hay un plato